im katholischen kanton uri stets die
gebaute erinnerung an die verunglückten
ohne kreuz und ohne prunk der architekt
pascal siegrist hat seit 15 jahren die
gotthard tunnel portale mitgestaltet
also auch diese gedenkstätte
zum ersten mal in der schweizer tunnel
geschichte wird den verstorbenen ein
denkmal gewidmet
die fortsetzung von der ganze tafel
befindet sich nun beton und natürlich
für die opfer stellt aber sind kein
grabstein sind nicht namentlich
zugeordnet und das besuchen sie so der
verleger wenn er das wort
wir danken für die verstorbenen steigen
von hier aus gen himmel
erinnerungen werden lebendig an die
gefährliche arbeit tun man muss den berg
kennen wenn man den berg nicht kennt da
läuft man auch oftmals sind dagegen
dann ist es meist passiert tunnel bauen
bedeutet den tod als bestandteil des
alltags zu begreifen
werth blindenbacher weiß dass 18 jahre
leitete er die baustellen in erst fällt
amsteg sedrun die sicherheit im berg hat
sich inzwischen sehr verbessert trotzdem
im jahr 2000 verunglückter ostdeutsche
andreas reichhardt
ja daran dass sie eben im schachzentrum
auf der nachtschicht ganz froh ist der
32-jährige mine arbeitet damals tief im
fels eine schwere bohrstangen löst sich
tötet indem sie fällt 700 meter tief
relativ einfach loslassen oder umsteiger
dollar
man kommt an
zwischen groß geschrieben das ist auch
aus
spielball
unser feld fällt dann musst du halt
er ist hoffnung größe wieder klar oder
das große betroffenheit harte männer zu
sein was aber natürlich auch der teure
rolex mit ca
denn ist im moment wirklich froh ist
wenn aus und gründen machen vorher etwas
wenn man nicht irgendwie des exportes
paar franken zugunsten europas tunnel
bauen bedeutet auch nach vorne zu
schauen
die mineure sind weitergezogen schuften
am nächsten verbindungs wunder der
gotthard ist ihr werk ihren namen stehe
nirgends einzig die verstorbenen
kollegen bleiben zurück für die ewigkeit
andreas reichert jakob diplom heiko
burrack albert ginzinger andreas torino
salvatore di benedetto torsten elsemann
hans georg kamml
denise